der rote gigant antares ist mehr als 600
lichtjahre von der erde entfernt ein
forschungsteam hat jetzt einen trick
genutzt und ist so an äußerst
detaillierte bilder von dem roten
überriesen gelangt bei der oberflächen
kartierung des roten giganten haben die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
einer mehr als überraschende entdeckung
gemacht extrem turbulente vorgänge in
der atmosphäre des riesensterns mit
welchem trick diese faszinierenden
aufnahmen gelungen sind und warum dieser
trick der astrophysik völlig neue
möglichkeiten eröffnet jetzt in klicks
um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
mehr als 600 lichtjahre ist der stern
antares von unserer erde entfernt der
riesige gasball bildet das zentrum des
sternbilds des skorpions und ist
außerdem das hellste objekt darin er
erscheint rötlich und wird deswegen oft
mit dem mars verwechselt antares hat
daher wohl auch seinen namen denn
antares heißt so viel wie gegen
aktuelles antares etwa 700 mal so breit
und zwölf mal so schwer wie unsere sonne
und er bläht sich derzeit immer weiter
auf denn bald in einigen tausend jahren
wird er wohl als supernova erlöschen so
die vermutung von astor physikerinnen
und physikern doch obwohl er so hell und
so groß ist ist es forschungsteams
bislang nicht gelungen überhaupt ein
detailliertes bild von sternen außerhalb
unseres sonnensystems abzulichten er ist
einfach zu weit weg um an gute bilder
von antares zu kommen hat sich das
forschungsteam aus chile eines tricks
bedient so konnten sie die oberfläche
dieses riesensterns detailliert erfassen
und sogar bewegungen darauf messen und
seine oberfläche kartieren für die
astronomie eine absolute sensation denn
das war bislang nur bei unserer sonne
möglich und in keinem fall bei einem
stern der 600 lichtjahre entfernt ist
das ergebnis lässt staunen sie
entdeckten verwirrtes gas und zwar viel
weiter entfernt von antaris als sie
bisher durch modellrechnungen angenommen
hatten das forschungsteam schließt aus
dass diese materie durch strömungs
bewegungen dorthin gelangt ist dies
liegt auch eine weitere entdeckung nahe
die atmosphäre von antaris ist rund
sechs mal dichter als es bisherige
modelle vorhergesagt haben umwelt
strömungen die alleine temperaturbedingt
sind würden nicht so weit nach außen
reichen so die astronomen und
gastronomen stattdessen vermuten sie
dass ein komplett neuer bisher noch
unbekannter vorgang zu diesen bewegungen
in der atmosphäre von antares führt fest
steht allerdings dass diese auf und
abbewegungen der gigantischen gas
klumpen in der sternen atmosphäre
äußerst heftig sind bis zu 20 kilometer
pro sekunde sind sie schnell und reichen
bis zu 1,7 stern radien ins all hinaus
dass es wirklich
riesig und fast nicht vorstellbar diese
neuen überraschenden details zum
überriesen landtages seien aber auch nur
durch das virtuelle teleskop des very
large telescope info meters der
europäischen südsternwarte eso in chile
zu sehen betonen die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
denn das war der trick sie haben vier
teleskope zusammengeschaltet und hatten
dadurch eine deutlich größere auflösung
als mit nur einem einzelnen teleskop
diese beobachtungstechnik könne man nun
aber auch auf weitere unterschiedliche
stern arten anwenden damit könnten wir
tatsächlich auf detaillierte
informationen zu ihren oberflächen und
atmosphären kommen eine völlig neue
dimension für die astrophysik jetzt
können wir viel weiter und viel genauer
in die ferne sehen als bisher möglich
ist wird also spannend was noch so alles
entdeckt wird hier bei pixum halte ich
euch natürlich dazu auf dem laufenden
wenn ihr kein video zum thema und zu
allen weiteren themen verpassen wollt
dann drückt man hier ein abo aufs auge
und vergesst nicht den auf die glocke
hier geht es weiter mit stern auf
kollisionskurs mit dem sonnensystem
entdeckt da geht es um einen stern der
unserem sonnensystem sehr nahe kommen
wird und wahrscheinlich einen asteroiden
regen auf die erde auslösen wird
spannendes thema also nicht verpassen
und drauf kriegen und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran